all right um do you want to get into r
kelly's really weird interview
did you see any of his really weird
interviews at the one where he said
i didn't do this because they already
said i didn't do it
and once you uh once you found not
guilty of uh having sex with underage
women and
sexually assaulting them that covers you
for that why is dorm mcdonald's saying
that uh
you know uh sometimes uh you get found
not guilty you know
uh and that uh that covers all murders
forever
you see what i mean like if i murder
royce
right and i get off at the trial that
means i'd still open my season totally
got off
just start killing everyone is that how
it works because
double jeopardy you can't charge me with
murder again
you can though it's one of the
case-by-case basis
oh [ __ ] they can't what did you do mike
oh no he's gotta
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
i think mike watched that movie with
ashley judd that double jeopardy movie
and he thought it was real life
why does it smell like smoke why is it
smelling smoke
hey i don't care just get it done just
get it done okay like whatever
whatever it costs hey what happened
we're just having fun we're having fun
there's a little bit we like to
we like to do somebody says don't forget
your bleach in line
well you can get the lime from the
[ __ ] tracks that [ __ ] felt
entertainment lays out
seriously you know those writers are
still complaining on twitter about it
guys i need a caustic chemical agent
that eats through flesh you guys know
any motocross riders
i get to maybe extract a culture from
their skin oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right um so r kelly
i'm not familiar who is this guy now he
was a fat comic that used to be on o
a all the time you know what dad you pee
on a girl's face
i'm not doing that again
oh [ __ ] sorry you know what i will say
this though about r kelly and robert
kelly
both of them were equally handsome in
the 90s good point
both of them look terrible now i want to
plea
man i want to plea dude like a plea deal
dude
sorry um
r kelly jeff glor and we are going to
begin here tonight with an
interview many have been waiting for r
kelly's first since being charged with
sexual
abuse last month gail king of cbs this
morning
just spoke with kelly the charges
against the singer involved four women
three of whom were allegedly underage at
the time now gail king she's the one
that's best friends with oprah right
all right in an interview just wrapped
kel
best the one that's best friends
bffs with oprah the one that has in the
same bowling team as oprah
lee told gail the accusations are lies
we have two clips here here is the first
they are still talking about you with
underage girls
do you still sit here and say you have
never been with underage girls can you
really say that
first of all it's a hell of a [ __ ]
way to open that that's [ __ ] really
you're out of the game you say that to
me
i had two cases
back then that i said in the beginning
of the interview that i would not talk
about
because of my ongoing case now okay
huh that's a weird way to say no yeah
well how about i just know that's a real
roundabout way to say
no i've never had sex with an underage
girl
what okay the only acceptable answer
other than no
is have you ever had sex with an
underage girl
like when i was in high school yeah yeah
when i was 15.
if if you really need absolute truth
then yeah but when i was 15.
i'm 35 now
[Laughter]
i will tell you this people are going
back to my past
okay that's exactly what they're doing
going back to the past and they're
trying to
add all of this stuff now
to that
well it's true they're trying to dig up
his past so you're peeing on underage
girls on videotape
there's not like a lot of gray area here
you don't get
what it's like though did this turn into
an everlast song
i guess you really don't know what it's
like
i was eating a rich man big i seen a
poor man whatever that [ __ ]
became a goddamn blue singer after he
left uh
what band was he in house of pain oh
that's what it was whitey ford well you
know
and two this guy like he's
i actually uh was you know
again you know some guys they were
telling me some stuff
and they rattled off a list of names
that uh
were going to possibly be um
you know in in the realm of this case
and now it's looking like remember i
mentioned june brown
june brown is this dude's everything
he's been r kelly's everything for a
long time yeah
uh i still very very confident that
we're going to see
june brown get dragged into all this
because now
as soon as remember when i've said june
brown's name the one day on rotc yeah
the next day michael avenatti came out
and said that there were enablers that
there were handlers
during the last case that could now
possibly be charged with obstruction of
jobs hi
avenatti sorry hi
creepy porn lawyer but yeah he said that
there's a possibility they'll reopen
uh an inquiry into that case and get
people for
possible obstruction of what they open
up see i think what will happen in this
situation is they really want to get r
kelly so they'll have him turn they'll
give him some sort of plea deal
to say everything that he knows like for
be let off with probate probation
you know what it's that's what i would
think they would do right like to just
think he's gonna do it takashi six nine
going to [ __ ] witness protection with
face tattoos dude by the way
you you could beat takashi 69 and going
into witness protection which obviously
that's a funny premise
he would still be more recognizable he
couldn't do anything in the witness
return
kelly that's definitely r kelly dude
come on man i own the space jam
soundtrack don't [ __ ] lie to me
to make all of the stuff that's going on
now feels real to people
but the past is relevant with you with
underage girls
absolutely no it's not
what the [ __ ] man this guy's a
full-blown absolutely no it's not he's a
complete sociopath by the way
because for one i beat my case oh well
then there you go
i by the way beat is always a weirdo
that was dude
that's exactly what i was going to say
beat is not the best word to use god i
was absolved i was exonerated
no no i beat my case which means that
okay when you beat someone you created
it
you were quick you can't double jeopardy
me like that you can't dude mike we were
kidding earlier by the double jeopardy
double jeopardy him
you can't once you have been well no
that's why i said it earlier because i
saw this clip oh you know it's like
basically it's like double jeopardy but
this is a different alleged raped
child right that's not how it works
that's why i was saying earlier like
i can murder somebody if i get off
that's it i'm gonna go with a
flamethrower into a mall
you can't do that it's not fair it's not
fair to know
when you beat your case you beat your
case but i'm not talking about the one
case in which you work
i'll kill you i'll piss on you right now
in other cases where women have come
forward and said
r kelly had sex with me when i was under
the age of 18.
or kelly was abusive to me emotionally
and physically and verbally
our kelly took me in a black room where
unspeakable things happen
this is what they're saying about you
these are these aren't old rumors
not true whether they're old rumors new
rumors why would they do this
not true well future rumors
kelly became much more emotional as gail
continued her questioning now he flips
and and correct me if i'm that's when he
flips we've never held anybody against
their will
i don't need to they why would i well
how stupid would you never know
kelly really stupid that's why this
whole thing is insane yeah but you know
that's that's the definition or kelly if
you're criminally insane
then then then uh logic doesn't really
dictate
uh anything here
with all i've been through in my way way
past
to hold somebody let alone four
five six fifty you said why how stupid
would i be to do that
pretty stupid pretty you'd be a pretty
and then to also film it on vhs and then
carry those tapes around with you
would also be very stupid oh
yes i didn't say yes stupid guys
i didn't is this camera on me yes that's
stupid
he's losing it he's [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] man that's stupid you
stupid
he is [ __ ] losing his [ __ ] why you so
stupid
why are you gay use your common sense
don't forget are you talking in the
mirror or the blogs forget how you feel
about me
hate me if you want to love me if you
want but just use your common sense
how stupid would it be for me to with my
crazy past and what i've been through oh
right now i just
think i need to be a monster and hold
girls against they will chain them up
black hustler listen to him it don't
even make sense like why would i want to
keep these hoes chained up in my house
like that's crazy
i don't know why i don't know because
see i'm not a man
who has any sort of an urge to keep
women chained up in a house
so you you're you have to explain it to
me right
bud let them eat and don't let them out
unless they need some shoes down the
street from the uncle
stop it y'all quit playing quit playing
i didn't do this stuff this is not me
i'm fighting for my life
this man is [ __ ] i mean he's always
been a piece of [ __ ] but he is
just it's fun it's fun watching him
[ __ ] crack it really is i'm not gonna
lie
[ __ ] this dude oh yeah no empathy for
him as i'm getting nothing but joy out
of this
there is much much more to this
interview that will air on cbs this
morning tomorrow and thursday gail is on
her way back from chicago
tonight
unreal uh jericho some of what we saw by
the way i
actually i have the little the rest of
the part that was on air if you want to
hear it
some 18 years ago i left dayton ohio
i don't think with two very bad knees
what had a dream the
girls would give him
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right somebody gets mocked for
having an honest moment
i know poor guy poor guy is a vulnerable
moment he's retiring after an amazing
career and that's
everybody's like
i used to play baseball
[Laughter]
oh i'm like tom barringer's character
immediately